hey everybody how's it going my name is
miyuko and welcome back to my channel
alright so today we're doing a q a video
because it's been a while
and uh i didn't really know what i
wanted to make otherwise
so we're doing it oh and before we start
i just want to say uh
hope you are doing well i know that the
world is continuing to be a little wild
but it seems like there's a little bit
of a light at the end of the tunnel
so there's hope which is great
it's been a while since we've had hope
so i hope that that hope is shining
brightly through your life as well
so i went on my instagram to ask you all
to ask me
any question that you might have around
personal life
mental health career stuff adulting
stuff kind of everything and anything
which is the theme to my channel
and thank you so much to brilliant for
sponsoring today's video so here we go
your go-to anxiety remedy yeah this is
usually what i do when i'm feeling
anxious i write myself in comfortable
soft stuff to warm myself up i usually
wear my glasses instead of my contacts
usually drink in
and sip in something warm and snacks
i mean really when i'm feeling anxious
i'm just like fearful of something
for oftentimes no good reason just my
brain is just like yo let's just be
really scared of something right now
and kind of like almost get into a panic
attack but not really but you are really
scared about something
so it's a lot of just finding comfort
and
uh fuzzy things warmth
and good things to eat and drink
that's just that's my formula for
anxiety
what equipment do you use for filming
photography
i have a canon eos r to film these kinds
of videos in most of my footage
for vlogging i use a canon g7x i have a
rode
boom mic as well as a zoom h4
n pro handy recorder i use a manfrotto
tripod
regular ass sd cards that everybody else
uses you can actually check out all of
the things that i use for filming
and making videos and all of that kind
of stuff at my amazon storefront
which is linked in the description box
down below how do you manage to be
consistent with projects and personal
growth activities
frankly i'm like not consistent the way
that i stay consistent is to stay
inconsistent like consistency is one of
the things that i'm just actually
pretty bad at how good am i staying
consistent with stuff
like long-term stuff yeah pretty bad
medium-term stuff uh-huh pretty bad
short-term stuff bad as well
so you say i'm pretty bad at being
consistent yeah
uh for those of you who've been around
for long enough you know that i've
started so many projects and i didn't
like finish them or i didn't keep them
up for very long but i'm actually kind
of okay with it
i feel like i have a realistic
expectation for myself that
i change i'm different every year and
every day and that's
fine as long as i'm just working on the
stuff that i really want to work on
and that i am like i do have some sort
of like
thing that i want to reach for and i'm
working towards that in some way
that's that's all i can ask for of
myself really because i think
consistency is really just all about how
do you go from a to b
uh knowing what b is but if i don't want
to get to b then i'll just be like
i don't i'm not gonna do it who is your
favorite tariff house
member oh so many ooh i mean like my
favorite just like everybody else is han
song
he's just like the coolest he's
he's the best he's the best guy on there
i think i also really liked leo from the
most recent season
he just seems really chill to hang out
with i also really liked vivi
from the most recent season i really
like her just like life values and stuff
i follow her on instagram i think she's
super cool
oh and like cena's queen she's she's the
queen she's great i
also really like her too did you ever
consider another career outside tech
yeah like weekly i think ever since that
i did my career switch from software
engineering to content creation i'm a
little bit like oh
i can do it if i try like i feel like
i've done it once before
so if i wanted to i could do it again
probably maybe naively over confidently
but you know i mean youtubing in general
is not like a forever career
i mean the platform's only been around
for like 15 years or so
so i'm constantly thinking about what's
the long term where do i want to go
next so yeah i think about this all the
time but don't worry i'm not going
anywhere like i still
like doing this right now i think if you
do see an evolution it'll be incredibly
gradual
so don't don't worry i'm not i'm not
going to career search yet
how often should i change my job as a
developer honestly as often as you want
to
the great thing about tech and software
development in general is that it's not
taboo to change your job often in fact
most software engineers
change jobs on average like every one
and a half to two years
after i learned that statistic on my own
i was just like oh okay so i don't have
to stay somewhere for five to ten years
if i don't want to so i don't think
there's actually any sort of like time
duration that's taboo
for jobs in tech i guess i mean
ultimately i think
to answer the question of how often you
should change your job as a software
developer
is really just based on what do you want
and are you getting that right now at
your job
how often do you take time to reflect on
yourself
like every other day or so
i don't have like a ritual per se where
i just like sit down
and i like journal or something like
that it just kind of floats in and out
of my head
oftentimes i reflect when i'm having
like a difficult
period in my life it doesn't even have
to be super difficult it's just like
if i'm not feeling it at a certain time
in my life that's
usually when i'll take time to reflect
to be like why am i not feeling it like
what's what's going on where you go
i mean i'll also reflect when things are
going really well and i'm feeling great
too
i just it's like almost second nature to
me like i if any time i have
idle time then i'm usually reflecting on
myself
or others or the world but you know
sometimes these reflections come when
i'm like
least expecting it as well like just
watching like a spongebob squarepants
episode
where i'm just like staring up at a tree
or i'm listening to my friend talk about
something super random it'll just happen
if anything my process
is that i let it happen and i welcome it
happening
if that makes sense you ever thought
about being a university instructor
slash professor
yeah that's like one of the things that
i'm considering that would be cool
my parents are both teachers so i always
thought it'd be really cool to teach
so if y'all are university people hug a
girl up you know
maybe i don't know i don't know what i
teach if i do teach it's not going to be
computer science probably it's probably
going to be
other things like just like career
readiness
or like introspection or i don't know
i mean in order to be a professor and
instructor i should probably get another
degree
but i don't know maybe universities are
open to me teaching
their students about kind of like more
real world skills about like software
engineering and how to build a good
product and stuff like that
so i got a couple of questions around
like comparison
so how does one stop comparing
themselves with other developers
how do you stop ah that's a good
question i'll tell you how i stopped i
stopped because i was just like i
realize at a certain point it's just
doesn't make sense to compare one person
to another
like if you think about all of the
different experiences and identities and
things
that make us who we are comparing it
is just like there's no better or worse
it's just
apples and oranges like some people
really like apples and some people
really like oranges
and oranges are great for vitamin c and
apples are great for apple pies
like there's just so many different axes
to compare
yourself to another person and you could
choose to concentrate on that
or you can kind of appreciate that so
many people are really good at the
different things that they do
and learn from them kind of maybe this
has to do with just like the whole
scarcity mindset of just like
what do other people have that i don't
have or like why am i
less than somebody else versus a
bountiful mindset of just like
everybody has cool skills
and we all are cool and we should
celebrate that and i want to learn from
everyone and anyone in that situation
but it is hard to not compare yourself i
think it's only human to do so so
it's okay to i just think if it gets to
a certain point
where you're like driving yourself into
the ground
so much that it hurts you as a person
i think that's when it starts getting
kind of harmful so i always stop myself
there
how's life oh thank you for asking you
know
life is good
i guess like that's my answer for most
of the time when people ask me how's
life
it's uh i can't complain but i mean it
could always be better but i mean i
think it's pretty good right now
frankly i'm in a bit of like a creative
rut
which happens all the time in youtube
world
in my work creative ruts happen
all the time and i think the first few
times i was i would always panic and be
like maybe i'm not cut out for this and
maybe
this is what i'm not supposed to be
doing with my life maybe like the well
has run dry of ideas and stuff
but now that i've been through a couple
of these i'm realizing like that's never
the case like it always comes back i
just need to like
sit and wait it out a little bit and
it'll be okay
so that's kind of how i'm feeling right
now which is also why i decided to do a
q a video
compared to other things so thanks for
watching
related to kind of this whole being
stuck thing i think some of y'all are
also in the same position
what advice would you give for those who
are feeling stuck slash
not experiencing growth oh man i don't
know it's i think it depends on how
you're stuck and how you're feeling and
what you're stuck about
and how you feel about being stuck and
stuff so it's hard for me to give like
blanket advice for it all
but when i'm stuck the things that
really help me to hear
advice wise is number one it's okay that
you're stuck people get stuck
all the time like there's no there's
nothing bad about being stuck in fact
being stuck
sometimes is a good thing because it
forces you to
stop and reflect and really just like
reground yourself before you move
forward again
i mean like i said this is like
literally where i am right now i'm in
one of those like
i want to do these things but i don't
want to do them
oh hey now i'm bored i'm really bored
but i want to do these things but i
don't want to do them okay
so now i'm bored so i'm just in this
vicious cycle of
being stuck right now and i'm just
letting myself bask in the stuckness
usually when i'm stuck i ask myself
questions like
what do you feel stuck about do you even
know are you
sad about being stuck are you mad about
being stuck
usually when i'm stuck i'm also just
very frustrated with myself so i'm just
like okay where is this frustration
coming from
do you is there's this expectation that
you have of yourself
that you're not able to meet live up to
why not what's going on here girl talk
to me
and sometimes i don't have the answers
to any of those questions and i just
have to like be like you know what i
have these answers right now i'm just
gonna go watch tv for like a couple
hours maybe i'll have answers later
other times i'll just like read other
books
just to like get ideas of answers
because sometimes
in exposing yourself to other ideas it
helps you to realize what's going on
inside
so recently i was reading big magic
which is a book about creativity and i
was just like i think this might give me
some answers about why i feel so stuck
and why it feels so
bad sorry that wasn't really advice but
it's hard to give advice about stuff
like that i think like you're just
always gonna be stuck
stuck is just a thing that happens to
people and i think
everybody comes out of it in a different
way and everybody needs different things
and i think figuring out
what that is for you is
your job in being stuck like i think
we all become stuck as a way
to ask yourself those questions like the
universe is like
maybe you gotta stop for a second and we
need
to really just like hone in to like who
we are
and what we're doing here and maybe just
rest a little too in the meantime
do you feel like you need to do videos
revolving around tech when you upload
yep very very much what was your least
favorite thing about
living in the bay area there were a
couple of things but i will talk about
one specific thing this was both my
favorite reason for living in the bay
and my least favorite reason for living
in the bay
it was the fact that there were tech
people everywhere
like i moved to the bay area because
there were tech people everywhere and i
was like that's so cool
but towards the end i was just like i
literally can't get away from tech
people
and that was just i don't know i wasn't
feeling it
there's just so many other ways to live
and
i forgot about those other ways to live
because
i didn't see it around me i guess like
the feeling of when you're coming back
from a vacation
and you're flying back to san francisco
and immediately at the gate
where you're boarding two random people
strike up a conversation
about different technologies i was just
like
i don't wanna think about work right now
i really don't i really i just
i don't wanna do that right now i
have enjoyed this vacation and i don't
wanna think about technology
so that's one of the reasons why i'm
just
very thankful to be living in san diego
now
a lot of questions around just like
moving and living in san diego in
general
is san diego your forever city or do you
plan to relocate to another city at some
point or
if i've ever thought about moving to
other states countries later in life
right now i'm really happy living in san
diego i'll make a video in about a month
because that'll be like my
one year mark about how it's been
living out of the bay area and moving
back to san diego
i i think just summed up i'm really
enjoying it it's been really nice
i do feel like it is a forever city but
i also know that my needs
and personality and all of those things
are gonna change so
i'm open to the possibilities of life
but i'm really happy where i am right
now
did you frequently feel so tired after
work where you didn't have time to do
what you want
oh yeah i mean that still happens like
in this day and age you are expected to
give
everything every bit of energy from my
life
into our work and sometimes i end up
doing that sometimes i love doing it
other times it feels like work is
sapping
the energy out of me but yeah i mean
i i'm i get tired like everybody else
after work and uh sometimes there's like
weeks and months where
i am just tired and i can't do anything
after work but usually there's a certain
point where i'm just like
i i gotta make time and space and
prioritize for the other things and work
so how can i make work
less tiring and set better boundaries
between myself and work so that i can
still live my life and do all of the
other things
how did you manage to transition from
life during college to life after
college
so internships really helped in this
because i had an expectation
of like what work life was going to be
but i will say in my first
month my brain was trying to absorb so
much new information about how to work
about the work itself about the company
about the product about
technologies that i was working with
that i was so tired
that one day of the weekend every
weekend for like two months i would
spend the whole day sleeping
like i'd wake up at 10 a.m hydrate eat a
little breakfast go back to sleep wake
up at like
4 p.m get up like eat dinner and then go
back to bed at nine
yeah i i just got so tired because it
was just such a different environment
from what i was used to in college so i
slept a lot and then after like i built
up enough energy and like the stamina
to withstand work life then i kind of
balanced all the other things in life
like social life
and exercise and eating well and stuff
and it was all one thing at a time
i think the social life part came first
because i was just like i miss being
surrounded
by friends like i was in college um so
yeah you just set up kind of like
weekly hangouts on the weekdays and
weekends
a lot of it has to be a lot more
structured sort of because your
schedule isn't crazy and stuff but i
found work life to be easier than school
life because it was less hectic
and so i had more control over my life
but there were moments where i was just
like
so like i just stopped working at five
and i have the whole
evening to myself like what do i even do
so
it feels like i got lost a couple of
times of how do i spend that time
but yeah if you want to hear more about
this let me know i'd be happy to make a
video about it i know a lot of y'all are
graduating and making this transition
right now or very soon so let me know in
the comments
oh relationship advice time how to find
a good boyfriend slash partner what
quality do you value in a relationship
okay this is something that me myuco
currently as a married woman thinks is
really important
as a value in a relationship uh this is
something that i
learned through being in the
relationship that i am right now so i
didn't know this when i was single but
if i could go back to single mojo and
tell her this this would be it
i think the most important value is just
like communication
it's so important things like you know
communicating how you're feeling and why
you're feeling those things
communicating your
own context and your background and why
you are the way that you are and how
your partner can kind of help you
through that
communicating what you need from your
partner and what you can provide for
your partner communicating boundaries
and limits
um communicating like when someone's
disappointed you
or when you've disappointed them
apologizing
from the heart and really meaning it and
actually taking the steps to change who
you are
like all of those things like
relationships take
so much work like literal work
and a lot of it is very emotional a lot
of it is very difficult
but i think if two people or more are
willing to do that work
and are willing to set aside things like
their pride and their ego and
put the other person first in all of
this
i think that sets a really good
foundation in a relationship
i mean i think that's how like two very
opposite people can come together
if you're able to communicate clearly
and well
and honestly and candidly and
authentically and openly
all those words mean the same thing but
i think that's just such a key part to
the relationship
and i mean that's something that i look
for in like all of my relationships not
just romantic too
like when i'm hanging out with friends
or becoming new friends with somebody
it's just so important to me now what do
you do on days when you just don't feel
like
working if i'm able like if i have the
luxury to do so i do this
but when i don't have that i will do the
bare minimum that i
absolutely have to do in order to not
get in trouble or lose opportunities or
hurt my relationships
and then i will not work but
i usually figure try to figure out like
what is the bare minimum
and i push through it sometimes you just
have to
and it sucks but what i do in
like helping myself get through that is
set up a reward system where i'm just
like will you go i know
this sucks and i know you don't want to
do it
at all but at the end of this we're
gonna go get ice cream
and not just any ice cream but your
favorite ice cream
and uh it's just gonna be great because
you're just gonna be able to enjoy the
ice cream being so proud of being able
to get through this hurdle in life
and you're just gonna have a great life
after that okay so just let's just
freaking do it now yeah and usually my
reward system is food related because i
love food again thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring today's video i
think one of the things that i've been
doing in an effort to try to just like
get out of this
funk and stuckness is to really just
like open my minds to learning new
things
so things like building new skills or
just exploring parts of the world in my
mind and all the things that i just
really hadn't done before
and brilliant is a great platform to do
so personally
i learn best when i'm practicing what
i've learned instead of just
watching lectures and brilliant is a
website and app built off of this very
principle
you learn best while doing and solving
in real time
you get instant feedback through
brilliance active and interactive
learning
program and i love stuff like this a lot
because there's no tests or grades or
anything you're literally just
learning to learn and having fun with it
too brilliant has something for
everybody whether you want to start with
the basics of math science and computer
science
or dive into cutting edge topics like
cryptocurrency
or quantum computing so make sure to
check out brilliant today by going to
brilliant.org
hello myuco where the first 200 people
will get 20
off the annual premium subscription all
right so that's it
thank you so much for watching this
video hope you enjoyed the q
a oh also let me know if you have any
other like videos that you would really
like
to see from me i'm taking video requests
and ideas because i'm slightly
uninspired right now
if y'all could inspire me with some
video ideas or
videos that you like that you've watched
on youtube that could help with the
inspiration
send them my way everybody alright thank
you so much for watching don't forget to
subscribe and i will see you next time
bye